marcel bénézet lé président de la
branche des cafés bars et brasseries du
groupement national des indépendants et
puis arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
messieurs bonjour à tous les deux arnaud
benedetti le coc vide est une réalité
pour sûrs avec il faut donc assurer la
santé de tous tout en assurant les
libertés de chacun c'est compliqué et
délicat
oui c'est compliqué et délicat si vous
voulez aujourd'hui le l'exécutif fait le
pari que l'urgence sanitaire et ça a été
validée par le conseil constitutionnel
peut permettre de restreindre un certain
nombre de libertés de libertés publiques
et mime même de prendre certaines
libertés par rapport au principe
d'égalité la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui on a un mouvement sur le
terrain qui manifestement est en phase
d'identification
il est enfin d'amplification non pas
seulement parce que il y aurait une
grande partie de ce mouvement qui serait
opposé par j'allais dire idéologie à la
vaccination mais on voit qu'il y à
beaucoup de gens qui dansaient cortège
pose les questions qui sont des
questions fondamentales d'un régime
républicain qui sont une question de la
liberté et de l'égalité ensuite il ne
faut pas totalement non plus exclure que
ce mouvement qui est en train
manifestement encore une fois de
s'amplifier puissent bénéficier d'un
mécontentement antérieures qui a pris
forme durant l'ensemble du quinquennat
emmanuel macron notamment à travers la
crise des gilet jaune il y a disons
aujourd'hui un risque pour le
gouvernement de se trouver confronté à
ils font d'agrégation des colères à
travers cette bataille que mènent les
opposants au passé ni caire alors le
basané terre est donc entrée en vigueur
1 ce lundi gabrielle at elle avait
assuré qu'une semaine de rodez seraient
accordés pour sa mise en place marcel
bénézet avez vous des retours au niveau
des restaurateurs qui appliquent ce pas
sanitaires alors nous serons parisse
dans la capitale et même en province ça
se passe très bien il applique le pass a
littéralement majorité tous sauf
certaines communes claude qui ont dit
que lol police municipale ne
contrôleraient pas mais les
restaurateurs font le job il contrôle le
pas salutaire parce qu'ils savent très
bien que si elle moins de problèmes si
nous serons fermés aujourd'hui ce que
nous voulons parce que fermer nos
établissements dont nous appliquons la
loi donc on nous impose qu'on nous
impose avec eux
parce que sinon nous allions à une
fermeture totale de l'établissement où
voyez vous imaginez le saison
touristique 100 bars un restaurant ça en
discothèque sinon aujourd'hui je passe à
l'inter était une solution est
certainement s'il est certain
qu'aujourd'hui
le vaccin et les teams des réseaux
sociaux
est-ce qu'on a eu des manifestations
pour ce vaccin vaccin si on avait rendu
la vaccination obligatoire on aurait
plus de manifestants dans la rue
aujourd'hui tout est bon à manifester
aujourd'hui sans les manifestations
fourre tout vous avez dit gilles vous
avez déjà les jeunes vous avez des
antilles va tous avaient des intérêts
dans un type a69 de la politique ça ne
sera pas une tournure politique que je
n'aime pas du tout à ce qu'aujourd'hui
il faut c'est sauver l'économie de la
profession de la mienne surtout c'est la
restauration l'hôtellerie
vraiment en danger aujourd'hui imaginer
pour s'obliger de refermer ce serait
insupportable donc aujourd'hui
il faut appliquer le pass qualité on
demande à me coller leur appliquer avec
rigueur parce qu'il arrive il en va de
nos l'ouverture notre établissement sis
à moineaux dérapage en soit fermé non
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui on peut
pas se permettre une fermeture
d'établissement
donc à mon avis je pense que ces
manifestations prennent autour d'une
tournure politique il ne plaît pas du
tout
arnaud benedetti si certains s'opposent
au passé hier c'est parce qu'ils ne
croient pas en son utilité donc à la
pertinence d'une vaccination massive
est ce un échec du gouvernement at il
failli dans sa mission de communiquer
aux français
je crois qu'il faut pas mettre tout sur
la communication évidemment des erreurs
de communication ont été commises par
l'exécutif mais il n'est pas le seul des
pays des gouvernements de pays
démocratiques avoir commis des erreurs
de communication
le fond
problème c'est aujourd'hui s'il ya une
incompréhension qui est en train d'une
certaine façon de prendre forme dans le
pays entre une partie de l'opinion
encore une fois et le gouvernement sur
cette question du pass sanitaires c'est
que on essayait il y a un doute sur
l'utilité de ce pass sanitaires aussi
qui se pose est ce que ce pass sanitaire
est un outil qui est un outil
véritablement sanitaires ou est ce qu
est un c'est un outil finalement qui
vise par une forme d'injonction en
attente a poussé ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés à se faire vacciner au
détriment de libertés publiques et
encore une fois d'un principe d'égalité
je crois que le fond du problème il est
là c'est que ont fait passer le pas
sanitaires pour un instrument sanitaire
mais la réalité c'est que le pass
sanitaire est aujourd'hui perçue comme
un instrument de lits de limitation des
libertés pour toucher encore une fois
ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés à se faire
vacciner il y à là je pense un sujet qui
est à mon avis essentiel et qui explique
vincent vraiment le fait une partie de
l'opinion aujourd'hui soit en réservé
voire en contestation vis-à-vis des
mesures qui sont prônées est mise en
place par l'exécutif il ya un autre
sujet c'est que vous avez aussi un
certain nombre de contradictions qui
sont inhérentes j'allais dire à ceux à
cet outil qu'est le pass sanitaires
c'est vrai que j'entendais l'un des
manifestants qui disaient non sans
raison en l'occurrence que vous pouvez
très bien prendre le métro en
l'occurrence où le ter et où il faudra
quand même qu'on nous démontre que le
virus ne circule pas dans le métro ou
qui ne venaient circule pas dans le ter
et que vous devez exciper à la terrasse
d'un café passe sanitaires pourquoi par
exemple un certain nombre de professions
sont astreintes à l'obligation vaccinale
ce qui peut se comprendre et d'autres ne
le sont pas donc vous voyez bien qu'il
ya tout à l'ensemble aussi de
contradictions qui sont inhérentes à ce
pas sanitaire qui ne rendent pas
finalement son acceptabilité plus facile
masse est labellisé dès lundi un
nouvelle extension de ce pass and i ter
à certains centres commerciaux dans des
départements français on sait que
l'application ne se passa ni terre coûte
cher aux responsables des établissements
est ce que le gouvernement sur ce point
là vous at il promis des aides
nous avons prévu une zone aussi prévu de
se rencontrer le 30 août avec le cabinet
de monsieur le maire monsieur l'elysée
doit se voir le 30 août donc on faire un
état des lieux de la situation
économique la note de la profession est
aujourd'hui le passé ni terre c'est un
outil de transition les gens ont pris
cela pour mana fro aujourd'hui la
liberté c'est d'être vaccinés on ne
comprend pas à quoi sur moi je pense
surtout à mes amis mes collègues qui
sont premières sens d'un sérieux ce pas
cette manifestation en ce moment où
c'est déjà le premier c'est difficile
ils se sont dans la contrainte de fermer
leur établissement des bouches de métro
fermée des années zones touristiques non
accessibles par partient passage de la
manifestation aujourd'hui vous savez
nous avons une profession qui est mise à
mal par tout ce qui se passe à une
incompréhension et je peux comprendre la
révolte de certaines personnes mais
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est vraiment à
la ligue bon pour moi ma liberté ça a
été de me faire vacciner et d'avoir
accès partout aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
que je ne comprends pas l'attitude de
certaines personnes
quand je vois des pompiers alors qu'ils
sont vaccinés puisque personne et que ce
vaccin est aujourd'hui on entend ce que
disent certains pompiers où certaines
personnes dans le milieu médical je
trouve que c'est un peu révoltant parce
que les réseaux sociaux sont quand même
un petit peu le facteur de tous et de
tout ce qui peut être entendu raconter
on entend tout de tout et n'importe quoi
même dans certaines interviews de gros
des manifestants pour être interviewé
jeudi aujourd'hui je suis très inquiet
parce qu'il faudrait pas que ça nous
amène tout ça dès ce qu'on a connu en
2010 9 avril et gilet jaune ou tout ça
donc journée pas revivre ça les grandes
villes de france
benedetti est ce que le risque
finalement de se passer ni terre c'est
que ça brac
les personnes qui étaient encore non
vaccinés
je ne sais pas parce que la réalité
c'est que ce qu'on a pu constater suite
aux annonces du président de la
république le 12 juillet c'est que
malgré tout le rythme de vaccination
s'est accru mais moi je pense
fondamentalement que aujourd'hui le
sujet dépasse la question du vaccin
c'est à dire que il y à aussi j'entends
ce que vivent mon interlocuteur sur le
caractère transitoire de la mesure la
réalité c'est que quand on regarde
l'histoire d'un état d'urgence
maintenant telle qu'elle s'est
construite depuis un certain nombre
d'années c'est que beaucoup de normes
qui sont édictées dans les lois
autorisant la mise en place d'un état
d'urgence tendance 8 à rester dans la
législation donc aujourd'hui certes le
projet de loi fin de la loi sur le pass
sanitaires indiquent que le pass
sanitaire devrait être finalement
suspendu à partir du 15 novembre mais
rien ne nous dit à ce stade compte tenu
de l'incertitude sur l'évolution de la
plagne épidémie la certitude de vent sur
cette évolution générale constate quand
même que depuis le début de cette
épidémie la plupart des pronostics qui
ont été faits à la fois par les
autorités publiques mais aussi par les
autorités sanitaires ou par les médecins
par les scientifiques ont été infirmés
par les c il est clair que on a
aujourd'hui un dispositif qui peut d'une
certaine manière en effet braqué une
partie de l'opinion publique parce qu'il
est considéré comme attentatoire à des
principes qui sont des principes
fondamentaux en république c'est-à-dire
des libertés de circulation les lire
telle travailler et des principes
d'égalité donc ces manifestations je
l'entends biens sont politiques mais la
politique sanitaire est également une
politique publique donc elle est
politique et il est naturel j'allais
dire presque en démocratie que un moment
donné les oppositions se manifeste alors
elles se manifestent dans la rue je
comprends tout à fait le discours d'un
certain nombre de commerçants qui ont
vécu en essais des chocs traumatiques
depuis plusieurs années suite un certain
nombre de mobilisation sociale
allemand mais l'arrêté c'est qu'on est
dans un pays qui est profondément civet
et cette manifestation elle traduit les
clivages qui traversent ce pays et que
manifestement l'exécutif d'emmanuel
macron n'a pas réussi à dépasser pour
parfois même légèrement exacerbe les se
passa ni terrain finalement on peut en
faire de lecture un certains
restaurateurs le voient comme un outil
qui vous empêchait on peut les empêcher
de remplir leurs salles et d'autres que
c'est un outil qui justement va leur
permettre de rester ouverte marcel
bénézet ce que les restaurateurs
pourront-ils survivre à un nouveau
potentiel confinement pas du tout alors
si jamais ils ont été confinés pour la
4ème vague même de l'ombre elle n'est
pas derrière nous la quatrième vague je
je je je sais pas comment ça se passe et
le mois d'octobre loin de fin septembre
début octobre à paris mais j'ai créé un
jeu près que malheureusement construire
de fermer si le parti les terres ne
marche pas ce sera une fermeture des
établissements et ça ce sera
insupportable pour nos commerces ne
devrait que quels qu'ils soient moi je
suis élu à la chambre de commerce de
paris ile de france je peux vous assurer
que c'est suivi de très près et sur
paris vous avez tous été confection tout
ce qui aide à la personne il ya beaucoup
de problèmes aux abus des rideaux qui
vont se blesser à une vie une cadence
insupportable aujourd'hui le commerce en
traversant à paris dans les grandes
villes ça devient sacerdoce aujourd'hui
vous avez des manifestations vous avez
toujours quelque chose qui se passe
devant votre porte et que vous pouvez
pas exercer votre première et ça c'est
une liberté nous dressons commerce aussi
quand on les manifestations des cordes
cuivres pour la manifestation cet
endroit en france mais nourrir son
commerce tous les jours de travail est
un droit aussi aujourd'hui on est
empêché de travailler donc là j'ai même
catégorie je suis très inquiet
machination à venir marcel bénézet merci
à vous d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'être président de la branche des cafés
bars et brasseries du groupement
national des indépendants avec vous
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire merci à
vous deux messieurs